it's a home game today in the village of
food you know the local football team is
out on the pitch fighting to win a
district tournament and their supporters
are here to root for them vladimir
morozov is the captain of the team he
was born in fettino and has been playing
for the club since he was a teenager
football is his life he says I'm now 43
but being part of the team makes me feel
young we're like a family and it doesn't
matter if we win or lose a game I play
because it makes me happy there's almost
always someone out on the pitch and feed
you know Vladimir's son is on the youth
team after the Serafim of church the
football pitch is the main attraction in
this village of 2600 inhabitants but in
Russia soccer doesn't get enough support
Vladimir feels he had hoped the World
Cup would give local football a boost
for instance the stadium in the city
closest to feed you know is over 50
years old but the World Cup windfall has
passed this area by much to Vladimir's
frustration the false crescents district
needs a modern Sports Hall of course
we'd love to have one here in Fayette
Eno but having one at all would be great
everything around here is kept up and
maintained by the team and the local
residents and the local administration
helps us out as much as it can
food you know is only a hundred
kilometers from Moscow but the World Cup
might as well be on another planet nine
of the international teams have their
training bases in the Greater Moscow
area and the government has invested
almost twenty-two million euros and
facilities to host them but people here
say not much has managed to trickle
through to feeding over
versus Parker things are quite just like
always there is some construction or
renovation going on in some places but I
didn't notice any big boomer building
frenzy and the run-up to the World Cup
they didn't construct an ice rink or a
Sports Hall here for the World Cup new
stadiums or something for the children
were built in other places maybe that's
why nothing's happening here the World
Cup raises Russia's profile
internationally but the people here in
Russia aren't benefiting at all the
Sports Minister for the Moscow region
disagrees and he says all the investment
in the World Cup is just the first step
there's been a great deal of progress
for the World Cup but tremendous change
more sports infrastructure was built in
the last five years in the Moscow region
than ever before our next task is to
completely renovate existing venues in
facilities some haven't been touched in
30 or 40 years and fallen into disrepair
and they have to be renovated so that
our children can practice sports in good
safe conditions the question is whether
there will be money left in Russian
coffers the country has already invested
over 9 billion euros to host the World
Cup the capital in particular was
spruced up for the international fans so
that they can get into the football
spirit
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
even feed eno is feeling the World Cup
fever especially because some here are
combining the game with a trip to the
banya a Russian sauna the beer is served
with dried fish his national team has
seen better times
according to Vladimir he looks back
fondly on the days of the Soviet Union
when he says football received a lot
more state support back then the squad
was world-class today it's all about
money we used to play for the love of
the game for our country our hometown
now in professional football it's all
about the money in fade you know we play
the way people used to for ourselves and
we give our all to the game you don't
see that much on TV anymore your wishes
there was more support for young talent
everywhere in Russia he's convinced
that's the only way to become a World
Cup winner